حرب الجنرلين التي اندلعت بسرعه بعد اخر
عشاء جمعهما لم تعطي عشرات الالاف فرصه
انتقاء مهربهم الالاف ممن يملكون سعر
التذكره والمقدره ب 400 دولار هرعوا على
متن حافلات متجهه لولايه كسلا في المنطقه
الشرقيه كسل الواقعه قرب الحدود مع
اريتريا هي تحوي معسكر ضخما للنازحين وتضم
جاليه اريتريه كبيره الامان التي برزت
امامهم وان لساعات سدت سريعا فخذلوا مرتين
اكثر من
3500 اريتري تم ترحيلهم لبلادهم قصرا وفق
صحيفه هؤلاء تم ابعادهم من المخيم ارسلوا
الى منطقه تسمى البوابه 13 قرب الحدود
تلقوا اوامر من قبل مسؤولي الامن الارتري
بالعبور الى اريتريا اذكروا ان الاف
الارتريين فروا سابقا من الجيش الارتري
الذي اجبرهم على الخدمه في اقليم تيجرايف
اثيوبيا وقدرت اعداد من استقروا في
السودان وقتها قبل اندل اع المعارك ب
126000 بينهم حوالي 75 الفا عالقين في
الخرطوم حيث يتركز القتال لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات